Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and
that number is 2192. David P, here's a caller
asking what is, quite frankly, a fair question
about Herschel Walker's runoff against Raphael
Warnock in the state of Georgia. Listen to this.
Speaker 3: Hey, David, this is Joshua from the
Philly suburbs. Yeah, very psyched about Tuesday's
results, especially with SHAPIRO and Fetterman. I
just wanted to call and to ask, do you think that
Herschel Walker's staffers, in preparation for the
December 6th runoff, are going to have to explain
to Herschel Walker that a runoff can be something
other than what he does when a girlfriend
shows up with a positive pregnancy test and
some post-election levity. Take care, man. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So I got the joke. I got the joke in
all seriousness. A few people wrote to me and
said, David, do you genuinely think Herschel
Walker understands the runoff? Like, do you.
Do you think Herschel Walker understands? Okay,
you lost, but no one got
50%. So now there's a runoff.
And it's only you and Raphael Warnock, and that's
why we're going to do more campaigning. Is that
something that Herschel Walker understands?
I think generally he understands it,
even if the particulars sort of get you know, are
able to are able to evade him. We're going to get
very involved in that race. That's a critical
race. Let me know what you think we should do
as a show about Walker Warnock, and we will
make it happen. We have such a great bonus
show for you today. We're going to talk about a
strategy that Democrats employed on Tuesday and
leading up to the election, which is elevate
election denying Republicans. In other words,
keep reminding voters they deny the results.
They deny the results. They deny the results.
We have exit polls now which tell us a lot
about whether that was an effective strategy.
We're going to talk about a New York court's
decision to block Democratic gerrymandering,
which is potentially handing the Republican Party
a lifeline in retaking the House. And we've talked
about gerrymandering many times before. We
will talk about it again today. And lastly,
women's basketball player Brittney Griner, who
was arrested, charged and convicted in Russia.
This is so horrible, is now being transferred
to a Russian penal colony, according to her
attorneys. It is horrifying what is going on. We
will talk about it and we will talk about much
more. How do you get access to the bonus show?
Speaker 3: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: It's super easy. You go to join
Pacman com. That is all there is to it. You
can use the coupon code. 24 starts now. And I
look forward to seeing many of you on today's
bonus show. If not, we'll be back tomorrow.
Unidentified: With a brand new show.